how do I know that the person I'm going
to hire is dang it
Gary I've got really good hiring advice
learn to fire fast you guys have your
ego tied up in your hiring you think
you're so good at hiring and then you
hire somebody and they're but you
may pretend they're not because firing
them admits that you were wrong so it's
your own ego that's holding you back my
ego is only balanced by my humility I
hired somebody for hundreds of thousands
of dollars 6 months ago interviewed him
three times I fired him one day into
working at Vayner media like check
your ego in the door you're not that
great at hiring but good news
nobody is